one of the most interested parties
tonight is the other republican
on the ticket vice president mike pence
joins us to talk about his boss's big
challenge tonight he joins us
from pennsylvania he's been there a lot
lately
mr vice president thanks for joining us
i know you can barely hear us over the
crowd there
set the table for us what do you think
happens tonight
[Music]
thanks brett great to be with you from
pennsylvania tremendous enthusiasm
here and we're literally just counting
the minutes
from when i know president donald trump
is gonna take our case uh to the
american people and
uh uh he's gonna take the fight uh
straight to joe biden we're gonna lay
out the contrast tonight
uh and it's on and the enthusiasm
uh here in lancaster pennsylvania is
just palpable
uh we couldn't be more excited and uh
this big watch party is just one of
thousands all across the country that
are going to be cheering our president
on tonight it's going to be a great
night you know mr vice president uh joe
biden and kamala harris both put out tax
returns today
it's clear that they are going to make a
big issue out of this new york times
story
i want to play a sound bite from senator
harris
you've got teachers you've got
firefighters you've got
you know frontline workers you've got
people
who are doing god's work to protect and
lift us up
paying more in taxes than the
self-professed billionaire
it's inexcusable how do you think that
is going to play and do you think it
makes a mark
well it feels like the same old same old
doesn't it brett uh
these same issues and allegations came
up in 2016.
the american people know uh president
donald trump was a job creator he was a
builder he paid
tens of millions of dollars in state and
local
taxes payroll taxes he created thousands
of jobs as he built
his business over many many years and
the president's uh dismissed the new
york times report
as false but i think the american people
know
that president donald trump brought that
experience of being a proven job
creator to the white house and it's why
in our first three years
by cutting taxes rolling back regulation
unleashing american energy
in great states like here in
pennsylvania that
we saw seven million jobs created and
it's also the reason why
uh we were able to in four short months
see more than 10 million americans
go back to work after the worst global
pandemic
in a hundred years so i think that's
going to be one of the big contrasts
tonight
if the democrats want to spend their
time talking about the latest
allegations from the new york times
they can but i guarantee you the
american people know that
they voted for a job creator in 2016.
and i know pennsylvania's going to vote
for four more years
of president donald trump in 2020.
mr vice president i just want to press
you on that on that new york times story
you know the president said that it was
all
fake news totally fake news in his words
but he also tweeted out
this the fake news media just like
election time 2016
is bringing up my taxes and all sorts of
other nonsense with illegally obtained
information and only bad intent i paid
millions of dollars in taxes
but was entitled like everyone else to
depreciation tax credits
so which is it a totally fake news story
or illegally obtained
documents that were real
well let me let me just say
you know i remember brett you know you
remember this came up
uh four years ago the same kind of
allegations and
and again the american people know that
when you create the kind of business
president donald trump created
you literally pay tens of millions of
dollars in state
and local taxes in payroll taxes when
you create
uh the kind of jobs and prosperity that
he created that speaks
for itself but all along the way people
also know
that this president and his business
despite what the new york times is
reporting i'm i'm very confident that
they took advantage of all of the
legal deductions and exemptions that
were available
in the tax code and the president
tonight may point out the fact that
when he was out creating jobs joe biden
was spending 47 years
in washington d.c helping to create that
tax code
while while president donald trump was
creating jobs so
you know honestly i just think this is
not where the american people are
focused
if they want to go with the latest
allegations out of the liberal new york
times
they can do it but the american people
know a job creator when they see it
and they know that when it comes to 2020
the man who can bring this economy all
the way back
by continuing to cut taxes roll back
regulation
and advance energy independence
including continuing the great fracking
that's driving
great energy renaissance here in
pennsylvania and around america is
president donald trump
i want to play a sound bite for you from
senate minority leader
chuck schumer and this is about the
judge judge amy coney barrett making her
way to capitol hill not meeting
with some senate democrats because they
are choosing not to meet with her
but he's saying this is all about health
care take a listen
health care is the most important issue
on the ballot to americans
and as americans learn judge barrett's
views on health care and so many other
issues
she will become less and less popular
and hopefully they will call their
senators and say don't vote for someone
who will take away my health care
what do you think about that supreme
court's on the topics tonight will come
up in this debate
well look it was my privilege today on
the president's behalf to escort
a judge uh amy coney barrett to capitol
hill and
we're very encouraged by the fact that
unlike senator chuck schumer
uh that republicans began today to meet
with judge barrett she's an
extraordinary person a brilliant
intellect
she loves the constitution is exactly
the kind of judge
the president promised the people of
pennsylvania in america that
that he would appoint but uh look you
know but
chuck schumer saying he's not even going
to meet with judge barrett
all the obfuscation uh notwithstanding
we we have every confidence that uh
when when the american people come to
know better and better this
extraordinary judge
when their hearing approaches they're
going to see the wisdom of president
trump's
choice and when it comes to health care
brett i i hope it does come up tonight
you know i think the 2016 election was
in so many ways a rejection
of obamacare i mean remember the when
joe biden was vice president they
promised that
you like your health insurance you can
keep it if you like your doctor you
can keep it uh they said that that
insurance premiums would go down none of
those things were true
one uh one outlet actually called it the
biggest lie of the last 10 years
well ever since president trump's been
working to lower prescription drugs
we've been creating new insurance models
the president's made it clear with
recent
executive action that we're going to
protect americans with pre-existing
conditions
but we're going to stay committed to
repealing and replacing obamacare and
giving the american people
great health care that respects the
doctor-patient relationship that's built
on free
market principles and doesn't put us on
an inexorable pathway
to socialized medicine which ultimately
is where
we're going to get into all that all
that tonight i just have a few more
seconds
mr vice president i want to talk to you
briefly about your preparation
we understand governor scott walker
former governor of wisconsin is your
prep partner playing kamala harris on
the other side
uh mayor pete buda judge is playing you
uh he's coming up on our show do you
have a message for him
about his preparation
uh well my message about next week's
debate
is i'm just counting the days it's an
incredible privilege for me to be vice
president to president donald trump
to have the chance to take the national
stage in salt lake city next week and
really lay out
what we've done but also lay out the
choice the american people face
i mean in the middle of a global
pandemic joe biden
and kamala harris want to raise taxes by
4 trillion dollars they
they want to stifle american energy in
the american energy renaissance that's
created
thousands of jobs in places like here in
pennsylvania they want to they want to
have an
activist court once again legislating
from the bench
i'm going to lay out that case i'm going
to lay out that choice
but tonight it's all about president
donald trump and
i know he's going to take our case to
the american people and
he's going to take the message straight
to joe biden i can't wait to see it
all right mr vice president we
appreciate your time from pennsylvania
we'll pass that on to mayor pete in a
bit